robert marchand 60 ans était une figure
de la commune président du club
d'athlétisme depuis 30 ans il entraînait
une vingtaine de jeunes de 7 à 18 ans
sur cette piste et leur transmettait sa
passion du sport
la nouvelle de son décès hier à nice
renversés par le camion fou s'est
propagée dans les rues de marcigny ce
matin avec beaucoup de tristesse
moi c'était quelqu'un de très discret
mes enfants fait d'athlétisme
quand il était entraîneur en fin de mes
enfants sont grands maintenant mes
enfants étaient très bien avec lui
c'était quelqu'un qui avait l'air très
très aimé des enfants en tout cas robert
marchand en est une vingtaine de
licenciés soit tout le club à monaco
aux meetings de la golden league pour
profiter au mieux du voyage le groupe
avait fait étape à nice pour voir le feu
d'artifice
c'est un garçon qui était très très
disponible je croisais assez
régulièrement le mercredi puisque
c'étaient les jours où il entraînait les
jeunes de son club et il obtenait de
nombreux résultats satisfaisants il fait
souvent la une des journaux locaux
le club d'athlétisme a perdu vraiment un
élément majeur de son organisation il
était à la fois le président un
entraîneur passionné de course à pied
robert marchand a lui même gagné 13
titres de champion de saône et loire sur
400 mètres et poussait les jeunes vers
l'excellence c'est quelqu'un qui a porté
au plus haut niveau un autre dimension
le club d'athlétisme avec ses trente
adhérents
il savait très bien recul qu'est aux
jeunes les valeurs du sport valeurs
aussi de l'effort magicien à ses heures
perdues son autre passion
robert marchand aura joué un dernier
tour avant de s'en aller
puisqu'aucun des jeunes qui
l'accompagnait n'a été blessé dans
l'attentât
ils sont attendus dans la soirée à
marcigny où une cellule psychologique
est prévu pour les accueillir